so this is a brief response and defense
of the scholars from the accusations of
the individual known as Daniel hu so in
Islam truthfulness and Justice are
praiseworthy traits while deceitfulness
and dishonesty are blameworthy traits we
also learn in Islam that even if we have
hatred for a people they should not stop
us from from being just Allah says in
his
book do not let the enmity and hatred of
others make you avoid Justice be just
that is near to piety the individual
Daniel hu due to his hatred for those
who tread the S methodology whom he
calls this causes him to deceitfully
label the scals of Sunnah as corrupt
government employees or corrupt
government agents and he warns from
following
them in response to these serious
accusations I
say number one Allah subhana wa tala
described the people of knowledge as
those who truly fear him as he
said it is only those who have knowledge
among his slaves that F law so how can
those with such a lofty description be
easily ridiculed by Daniel
yes a scholar may go astray but where is
Daniel's concrete evidence that these
Scholars have left uprightness and the
fear of Allah concerning their
judgments number two the prophet
sallallah he said in the
authentic they will not cease to be a
group from my manifest upon the truth
they will not be harmed by those who
oppose them until the command of Allah
comes the imams of the religion from
them
iMed said that this group
is
so the de bun Scholars who Daniel has
praised in the past or are the mountains
of knowledge like
IM
and the latter who dedicated their lives
to and teaching it and adhering to it
they are closer to the description of
the Victorious group in which the
messenger of Allah s Al wasallam spoke
about number
much of the Islamic umah placed their
trust in the scals of Sunnah who Daniel
labels government agents and in
particular the schols of Sunnah in the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia just let them
look at the books of fwa such as the fwa
of the legend
and and he will find people from all
corners of the Islamic world and other
countries who send their questions to
these and they are pleased at the
verdicts of these and their Affairs of
their worldly life and their Affairs of
their religion
but it seems that Danny was upset
because this same trust is not placed in
him and those deviant Scholars that he
promotes and
defends number four Scholars who have
not worked in government capacities have
prayed Scholars who work or have worked
in government capacities so we find
numerous statements for example
from praising
IM
praising he praised knowledge and
recommend that the students ask them and
take Knowledge from them so the question
is do we take Knowledge from a demagogue
who speaks about big matters far above
his pay great while being dishonest at
the same time or do we listen to
Scholars who have dedicated their lives
to teaching the book and the Sunnah and
nurturing the um upon this we ask Allah
subhana to suffice us from his evil and
those like
him
Muhammad